[Music]
so december 4th of 2003
a uh a father
tells um
you know he goes out for a night in the
town and he he um
he was on his way back to pick up his
kids from the babysitter's home
and then he disappeared
completely disappeared this is 2003.
picked up the kids he was never seen or
heard from again
and just last week
they found
uh his body in a car that they fished
out of a [ __ ] ravine whoa
damn sucks for the kids dudes we're
matching those kids it's like dad's
coming to get us and you're with the
babysitter and then you never see that
[ __ ] again and then they just found
out that he he did he died from like he
didn't disappear like [ __ ] abandon
his family like he died how long was he
in that car 2003 2003 holy so that his
like bones and [ __ ] was on the steering
wheel like that it was yeah bones on the
steering wheel holding the steering
wheel yeah yeah
bonus
bone hands like they risk dig the car
out skeletons [ __ ] with a hawaiian shirt
sunglasses yeah well looking like fear
and loathing and [ __ ] because he was
going to go on vacation that's how they
found him and then finally the
babysitter was like clock off
that's a good movie called the
babysitter like she's like she had one
job and she ain't gonna [ __ ] it up she
had one job and then she's like still
the babysitter till adulthood yeah she
adopted the kids she had no choice yes
and now the guy owes her millions of
dollars but he's dead
mr boneham and that's what she was
looking forward to the whole time she's
like once the dad comes back i'm about
to get paid like it's like a lien sale
when you leave your car at the mechanic
they just own it after a while with a
sign that says after 30 days yeah
happens with kids and babysitters
babysitters especially we're all
laughing about this tragic story yeah
what else would we do yeah it's a dead
deal was there was there a sign of like
uh an accident or the car was just found
they just they found the car in the in
this um waterway and they um
they uncovered well first they they were
inv they were investigating waterways
just in general just for maintenance
and they found using technology they
found there was there was this vehicle
in there and then when they pulled it
out they found his body and then they
connected the license plate to a cold
case from 2003. i wonder if they just
like to the forensics to find out if it
was suicide or if it was an accident
they just look at the expression of his
skull if he's like
versus a smile versus like relief
or maybe he falls asleep with the wheels
he's just like that
not only did the skulls just here
handing on his tight though do you think
there should be like a giant initiative
now that there's this apparent
technology for like everybody to check
every [ __ ] waterway and lake and
stuff i bet you they find a [ __ ] ton
of dead people did i tell anything i'm
like what if we could empty the ocean
like in one second like imagine all the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you'd see in there dude
that shouldn't be a bunch of dead fishes
yeah well that too i would definitely
unfortunate part but if you could just
like for some reason remove all the
water real quick and just look at it
it'll be sunk in cities you know they
found one in india when i don't know
when but i saw a documentary where on
the coast of india some divers were
going down looking for some oil [ __ ] and
they're like hey this looks like stairs
and then they [ __ ] uncovered a whole
ass
city that sunken that used to be on the
coastal area
which they say like oh there's a mini
ice age and when that ice cap melted it
just covered up a lot of the coastal
areas all over the world holy [ __ ] well
they found one next to brazil too and
when they looked at it it was because a
guy left his sink on
the whole [ __ ] city wow crazy
what bandits
i think they plugged
by the time they found out it was too
late it was already going down it was
too late
it's too late for the city yeah just
leave it on yeah that water bill must be
crazy dude
it was over sixty thousand dollars
sixty thousand it's never been paid yeah
i heard that's what i read
you know they say um
what is it venice venice is sinking yeah
in italy oh yeah yeah oh we gotta go
there before it goes underground that's
gonna be gone within a hundred years
apparently you see it when you go there
there's like parts of like the cathedral
that's wet you see the tiles going under
the water i heard there's like times in
the year where the whole place is just
like knee-deep in water all the venice
already yeah there's footage already
during like the pandemic they're like oh
it's been crazy flooding and then we saw
the footage there where during the
pandemics nobody was out like [ __ ]
fish were like swimming around and stuff
there's no reason that's right i
remember that i heard miami sinking too
my sister lives there and everyone that
lives locally they're like yeah these
waters are way lower than it used to be
higher sorry or higher the cubans are
twerking too hard and then every time
they shake
the ground gets pushed down because it's
like a jackhammer effect you know is
that really happening
a lot of cubans like to twerk the bush
the books the butt shapes yeah
do you think this guy died of foul play
or you think it was just like a total
accident oh there's they're
investigating it still because
his body was in such a strange condition
i remember as a kid you know in the mail
you'd always get that card that's like
disappeared or whatever yeah and like
you get one every week and i'm like why
the [ __ ] people disappearing all the
time
i never got it remember the milk carton
faces the missing milk
i'm like are these [ __ ] people really
disappearing this much i started seeing
it so much i actually thought it was a
fake as a kid i was oh this is like
[ __ ] national enquirer type [ __ ]
they're just trying to scare me
especially when you see the dates have
you ever looked at that yeah some of the
dates are so far back like this dude
doesn't look like this anymore they show
a picture of a baby and they're like
this chick could be 25 now i'm like too
late there how the [ __ ] am i supposed to
match this face to a 25 year old it
still looks like a baby though let's
sketch it or they have to really give
you like this is what they might look
like but you know that that tech back
then this is like 25 years ago you don't
know if they've been eating too many
sandwiches and they got big or whatever
exactly chances are if they're kidnapped
they're eating tons of sandwiches yeah
they should they should have like
they should have gave three different
photos like if they ate too many
sandwiches if they're average size like
dude if you live next to quiznos you're
gonna eat a [ __ ] up sandwich because
that's just how it is that's that's on
the list like you got the sandwiches all
right let's kidnap this [ __ ]
if i did get kidnapped though i hope i
got kidnapped by a culinary genius and
not like a
you don't mean like what's this
that's probably best case scenario [ __ ]
yeah man try my new menu joe the person
comes and goes
four forums like are you a culinary
genius
pretty sure nobody's ever thought about
this
joe's the guy that they like kidnapped
him but then within like 30 minutes they
drop them back off like [ __ ] this
i think that's exactly why i never got
kidnapped as a kid
did you ever did any of you ever come
close to being kidnapped as a kid
uh
i was one time jealous because i wasn't
abducted while my friends almost got
abducted
i'm like how come they wanted to [ __ ]
play with you guys but not me you know
you felt insecure it's the jealousy of
not getting abducted yeah
i was a stranger at the park you know
having conversations with all my friends
except me
and i was just like when am i going to
get any attention from this weirdo dude
when the kid [ __ ] that teacher
remember the hot teacher and i was like
mary kay later or some [ __ ] though the
little the samoan kid yeah yeah she was
funny and i remember a utah lady oh yeah
oh the one that they got married and had
a kid yeah
wait is that texas she was a lg one i
remember i was that age where it's like
god damn i would love to [ __ ] a woman
like that
yeah you know what i mean it's called is
it called like uh jail baiting yourself
like reverse molestation because i
remember having fantasies like as a like
fourth or fifth grader right and then
you're just like man like girls my age
so weird looking but like college girls
or like women or like the teacher
they're so
beautiful they got like big boobs and
they don't have like braces and stuff
yeah yeah exactly right you didn't like
girls your age at that age you're like
watching portals for the first time
you're like dude i don't want my dick
sucked you start fantasizing about the
girl next to you she's got braces you're
like oh yeah
weird no it's always women for me and
like like a grown ass woman yeah but
like it was like especially our age like
[ __ ] we all wanted to [ __ ] madonna
and stuff
madonna that's weird now i i had a thing
for paula abdul back then oh yeah i
thought it was hot yeah my elementary
days paula abdul i wanted to have orgy
with the whole baywatch cast yes
baywatch was my [ __ ] dude pamela was so
i know baywatch was so even apple off i
saw her uh in a magic show in like 2004
yeah she was like doing it was called
hans clock the beauty of magic and i was
in vegas and i [ __ ]
saw the show and pamela anderson was
like the magician's assistant did she
get cut in half yeah she got all that
[ __ ] she got cut in half saw it in half
they cut her hand
cut her head off was she introduced as
the pamela anderson or she was just like
no they picked her up from the audience
then she did 14 shows
no yeah it was part of the whole thing
like it's like hans clocked the beauty
magic with pam anderson which is such a
weird thing but yeah i remember um
married with children always had the
hottest oh dude and it was it was not i
wasn't that much into christina
applegate or kelly but her friends yeah
the other like side characters how are
you not in the christina applegate her
friends were hotter yeah the guest star
yeah she had this redhead friend that
was always always like damn i forgot
your name but she's one of the hottest
girls and i was like you should be on
the show that's because they casted the
side characters on looks alone so they
could afford to just pick the best
looking and not the best actresses like
you know they always played the bimbo
yeah pam was on uh tool time too right
yep oh yeah she was she was the tool
time chick yeah oh you're right she was
the assistant she replaced her with like
someone got too big and they like they
they switched it out yeah did tim allen
ever get in trouble for stuff no way
dude yeah dude you know tim allen was a
gangster right he was a drugstore
drug dealer
but it was pre-career right
it was like pre
[Laughter]
same with the harrison ford was a drug
smuggler yeah no he was a dealer like uh
when when he got through with his
millennium falcon
do you remember do you remember the the
um
the singers the mamas and the papas yeah
yeah all the leaves
so they were friends they were friends
with harrison ford and they only knew
him as their dealer
and then when he was on star wars and
they finally like they're like so like
don't watch movies when they saw it they
did an interview and they were like that
guy's my dealer
they outed him
but it was like years ago that he was
selling them he fits that role very well
yeah he's a smuggler bro we need we need
more of those uh success stories yeah i
know that's great it's like past the
statute of limitations too well the good
ones out there because there are good
smugglers out there and good drug
dealers out there but they're they're
they're they're doing the gel method
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you